antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir et bienvenue sur
le plateau d'antenne 2 à la une ce soir
lüscher une nouvelle affaire en deux
volets d'un côté les ventes d'armes
françaises à l'iran de l'autre une mise
en cause du parti socialiste mais il en
cours ce qui semble de moins en moins
évidente ce soir commentaires et
explications dans quelques minutes
gorbatchev salle l'avenir de l'urss les
réformes avant tout il commente
l'histoire ménages staline condamnerait
ginette et fraudes qui nous écouteront
le petit-fils de trotski il dit qu'au
mexique 72 heures décisives pour une
petite américaine de trois ans tabata a
subi la transplantation de cinq organes
15 heures d'opération la fillette se
porte bien
10 ce soir les médecins
deuxième journée de jacques chirac en
israël matinée d'émotion à yad vashem le
sanctuaire de l'holocauste après midi
politique avec la paix la coopération
franco-israélienne et les droits de
l'homme
thierry champion passe l'équatorien
basse gomez en deux sets à bercy la
première surprise est la chute d'une
tête de série le soir sur antenne 2
duels français entre henri leconte une
journée supplémentaire de détention pour
marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés avant d'évoquer
la sphère du cher une affaire vous savez
qui a rebondi ce week-end et qui
débouche aujourd'hui sur une contre
attaque du parti socialiste
arrêtons nous quelques instants sur une
autre image symbole qui mérite elle
aussi vous allez le voir la une de
l'actualité depuis 21 jours à carmaux
treize mineurs étaient enfermés à 230
mètres sous terre 21 jours de
protestation et de grève de la faim pour
s'opposer à la mise en place d'un plan
social de reclassement aujourd'hui les
mineurs ont cessé la grève de la faim
trois d'entre eux sont même remontés à
la surface
mais les autres s'accrochent il
s'accroche désespérément au puits de
mine
le poids des hommes et de leurs
certitudes face à la réalité économique
un reportage de françois jolly le
charbon à carmaux au fond de la mine
c'est fini il y a deux mois le dernier
puis a fermé départ à la retraite
mutation près de 700 personnes sont déjà
reconverti presque le cas d'une
soixantaine de jeunes il y a trois
semaines 13 d'entre eux sont descendus
occuper le front
aujourd'hui ils sont encore dit à faire
grève à 280 mètres sous terre
les emplois qu'on leur a proposées
ailleurs moins bien payés ils les
refusent
ou alors ces mineurs ne font pas la
faire de leur nouveau patron s'était
refusé tout le temps sur un projet
médical ou un problème comme jérémy nos
jeunes j'ai pas eu de qualification si
j'ai mon diplôme je n'ai pas exercer
donc il y avait toujours un point où qui
n'allait pas et on m'a dit non
faire au moment où ça ne va pas et alors
sorti sur toujours là où il en fait la
houillère ils ne veulent pas la quitter
ils ne conçoivent pas leur vie autre
part loin de cette région de leur maison
de leur famille ici à carmaux par mois
c'est qu'armand quoi c'est le pays de la
mine
mon mari aimait son travail que ce soit
au fond ou jours et il y croit
moi j'y crois aussi on sait qu'on peut
rester à carmaux tout ce qu'on espère
savoir des négociations le plus vite
possible que tout ça finisse et pour en
finir avec cette grève les mineurs
demandent leur maintien dans ses
houillères du centre midi ils veulent
conserver le statut de mineur leur
salaire entre 6000 et 8000 francs par
mois
leur solution travailler à la découvert
cette mine à ciel ouvert près de carmaux
dont l'exploitation doit durer encore 25
ans mais là le nombre d'emplois et
limiter l'effectif complet selon les
charbonnages de france
la direction ne veut donc pas renégocier
le départ de ces soixante jeunes
nous avons prévu un effectif qui
correspond à l'optimum économique du
fonctionnement de carmaux centrée sur la
découverte sur la cokerie et ce
personnel n'a absolument pas sa place
dans cet effectif en 30 ans 4000 emplois
ont été supprimés à carmaux aujourd'hui
10 homme ou fond d'un puits s'accrochent
encore à leur mine et social toujours du
nouveau pour la chapelle darblay le
tribunal de commerce de nanterre vient
de désigner le groupe pinault cascade
comme gérant du premier groupe papetier
français c'est la solution que
souhaitait apparemment le ministre de
l'industrie alain madelin monsieur
madelin estime qu'il s'agit d'une bonne
solution par ailleurs les repreneurs
rembourseront 1 milliard 500 millions à
l'état comme correspondant subvention
versée à l'entreprise depuis l'année
1983 ouvert il y à plus de 18 mois en
février 86 la sphère lüscher a donc
connu ces derniers jours une brusque
accélération
je rappelle brièvement les faits ce
week-end nos confrères de l'express et
du point ont affirmé que le parti
socialiste aurait profité financièrement
des contrats à passer illégalement par
la société lüscher avec l'iran
depuis vous le savez les événements se
précipitent charles hernu ancien
ministre de la défense affirme qu'il ne
portera pas le chapeau je cite ces
propos le parti socialiste demande la
publication du rapport qui a mis le feu
aux poudres
enfin de source judiciaire on apprend
aujourd'hui qu'au stade actuel de
l'instruction rien ne permet de mettre
en cause le parti socialiste le point
avec olivier lerner la réaction du parti
socialiste ne s'est pas fait attendre
jean-jack queyranne le porte parole
annonce que son parti va demander la
publication du désormais fameux rapport
barba ce rapport classé confidentiel
défense remis à andré giraud est entre
les mains de la presse
affabulation calomnie le parti
socialiste dénonce une vaste opération
politique et demandent réparation
trois jours avant les élections de mars
86 le ministre de la défense de l'époque
paul quilès avait déjà pris les devants
en déposant une plainte contre la
société du cher et son pdg daniel
dewavrin paul quilès est bien placé pour
savoir qu'aucune livraison d'armes ne
peut échapper à la connaissance d'un
ministre de la défense en exercice il
est au courant par l'intermédiaire de la
cia mgc le comité interministériel
l'exportation de matériel de guerre qui
donne l'autorisation d'exportation de
volume donné le matériel d'armement et
qui donne aussi la destination de ces
matériels et là en l'occurrence en
affaires le cher et eu détournement il
cargaison devait être livré à certains
pays il se trouve que n'a été livré à un
autre pays en l'occurrence diront
détournement en effet 450 milles au but
ont été livrés à l'iran par la léchère
destination officiel brésil thaïlande et
pakistan mais les bordereaux de
livraison sont des faux ces munitions
alimente aujourd'hui l'armée iranienne
mais selon le rapport barbade et 1984 la
dgse aurait alerté le ministère de la
défense de l'existence même de ce trafic
charles hernu conteste ce point du
rapport autre point formellement
contesté celui qui souligne que le ps
aurait touché une commission le ps
contre attaque
paul quilès indigne et dénoncent
l'amalgamé entre les faits la sphère du
détournement et les accusations portées
à l'égard du ps
il est encore une fois j'aurais
peut-être très choquant que les
informations de ce rapport que je ne
connais pas je n'ai pas eu connaissance
soit ainsi répandu dans l'opinion
publique et plus grave encore que l'on
mélange des éléments qui semble-t-il
sont des faits indiscutables ceux qui
m'ont amené à déposer la plainte et
toute une série d'hypothèses et
d'accusations très graves qui sont mises
au conditionnel le mélange entre ces
faits et ces accusations conditionnelle
créer un climat tout à fait détestable
et en tout état de cause qui par
certains aspects frise la calomnie
le dossier n'est pas refermé pour autant
un gros point d'interrogation demeure
qui au ministère de la défense a couvert
cette opération la réponse n'est pas
dans le rapport parent pas
monsieur méhaignerie bonsoir dans une
vingtaine de minutes vous serez en
direct sur antenne 2 l'invité de l'heure
de vérité alors comment est ce que
l'homme tranquille de la majorité
barrister apprécié semble-t-il du
président françois mitterrand a réagi
devant ce genre d'affaires c'est une
affaire qui apparaît grave et ça doit
être pour moi un électrochoc pour
l'ensemble des partis politiques
il faut à tout prix parvenir un contrôle
du financement des partis politiques et
sur leurs dépenses et sur leurs recettes
et je crois rappelé devoir rappeler ici
un premier résultat obtenu par la
famille politique je préside le cds
c'est l'interdiction de la publicité
politique à la télévision pour les
parties car c'était encore une source de
financement supplémentaire vous serez
suivi par les autres partis politiques
je crois que les événements que nous
connaissons et qui crée un climat
détestable doivent conduire tous les
partis politiques à se mobiliser sur un
financement beaucoup plus claire et
contrôler des partis politiques je le
crois petite question annexe monsieur
méhaignerie vous avez souhaité que votre
homologue allemand oskar schnyder soit
présent sur le plateau ce soir
permettez moi de vous poser une question
moi j'ai l'impression qu'en allemagne le
public et la classe politique sont
beaucoup plus dur avec ceux qui sont
mouillés dans les affaires qu'est ce que
vous en pensez monsieur le ministre est
tout le temps politique qui on
reconnaîtra une infraction aura des
conséquences fâcheuses pour sa carrière
vous pouvez nous citer des exemples il y
avait le cas du compte au trésor par
exemple il y en a bien d'autres
tout le monde s'y tenir car sinon ce
serait la fin d'une carrière politique
si un homme politique ne s'y tenait pas
merci messieurs et tout à l'heure sur le
plateau de l'heure de vérité à partir de
20h30 je signale aux téléspectateurs
qu'ils peuvent d'ores et déjà poser des
questions à pierre méhaignerie en
composant le 47 87 11 11
précédée du 16 et du ainsi vous appelez
de la province staline suspecté d'avoir
commis de grossières erreurs politiques
trotsky accusé d'avoir provoqué des
scissions au sein du parti communiste de
réflexion importante formuler ce matin
par mikhaïl gorbatchev à l'occasion du
coup d'envoi du 70e anniversaire de la
révolution d'octobre
après avoir commenté l'histoire le
numéro un soviétique a lancé une mise en
garde contre les montées des forces
conservatrices un discours de trois
heure prononcé devant une assemblée qui
réunissait tout ce que l'urss et le
monde communiste compte de puissants
sème la restructuration et mikhaïl
gorbatchev a pris date devant l'histoire
pour dénoncer à voix haute cette fois ci
les grossières erreurs politiques
commises par staline et son entourage
culte de la personnalité répression
arbitraire
un coup de chapeau remarquer au courage
du camarade khrouchtchev mais ces
tentatives de changement reposer sur une
démocratisation insuffisante une
classique dénonciation des 20 ans de
stagnation brejnévienne et une
remarquable discrétion sur les deux
prédécesseurs de monsieur gorbatchev
pas un mot sur messieurs andropov et
czerniak au même quand on cite
abondamment lénine l'histoire récente
reste choses délicates les réformes
économiques et politiques de monsieur
gorbatchev ne manquent pas d'adversaire
intérieur dans les deux ou trois ans à
venir
les conservateurs mettrons tout à profit
pour discréditer la ruche procuration
cela le chef du kremlin a tenu à le dire
lui-même
jean martineau on a l'impression
gorbatchev n'a pas tout à fait les mains
libres 1 c'est moi qu'on peut se dire
disons pas exactement mais disons que le
numéro un soviétique est bien conscient
qu'il est loin d'avoir convaincu tout le
monde chez lui alors staline dénoncé
staline cela rassure les intellectuels
les scientifiques voir les occidentaux
mais les puissantes organisations
d'anciens combattants en aime guère que
l'on touche à leur vénéré chef de guerre
et ce matin monsieur gorbatchev a bien
soin de trouver aussi quelques qualités
au camarade staline économie plus de
disciplines moins de subventions dans
les usines la base grogne travailler
plus et peut-être demain ht - monsieur
gorbatchev n'a pas promis que des roses
politique enfin beaucoup de cadres du
parti qui ont peur de perdre de leur
pouvoir espérer bien changer de
génération sans changer de politique
au total encore beaucoup de soviétiques
à convaincre revenons quelques instants
sur le discours de monsieur gorbatchev
il y à bien longtemps que le nom de
trotski in avait été vraiment évoquer en
public tout au moins en urss
chez nous en europe de l'ouest certains
parlé récemment d'une possible
réhabilitation et de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique au mexique
le petit-fils de trotski compte
visiblement ce pour un geste ne
serait-ce que petit du numéro un
soviétique sans pour autant parler de
réhabilitation
corinne pertuis
je savais que que le coût allait venir
donc c'était inexorablement ils allaient
souffrir un attentat que staline ne
finirait pas l'assassiner side le savez
parfaitement après l'attentât raté de
mai 40
trotsky transforme en bunker la maison
dans laquelle il vit avec sa femme et
son petit fils a mexico le 20 août de la
même année le coup fatal lui est porté
par son secrétaire en fait un agent de
la guépéou je retournais de l'école
c'était environ cinq heures de l'après
midi
je suis à l'aise en direction de la
bibliothèque et par la porte entrouverte
sur mon grand père allongé par terre
noire entourée de ses camarades de
nathalie il a eu encore la présence
d'esprit de donner des ordres des
billets vous cette enfance mon
petit-fils n'adopte pas voir cette scène
éloigner le dessin
créateur de l'armée rouge président du
soviet de saint pétersbourg en 1905
théoricien marxiste lev davidovitch
bronstein lytro ce qui cristallise
bientôt la ferveur et la haine ils
dénoncent les dangers du bureaucratisme
prône la révolution permanente
internationale il s'oppose à lénine sur
la notion de dictature du prolétariat
traité de petit bourgeois
contre-révolutionnaires il est banni en
1927 lui ses amis
staline n'aura de cesse de les
poursuivre
la fois essayer sinon qu'il a sollicités
y est là tuez les fils exterminés parce
que toute la famille pas seulement les
amis mais tous les compagnons d'armes de
lénine filles en liquide et dans l'est
les purges que le réalisa staline
ambassades et mensonger des accusations
de fraude tout à fait force 1987 le
temps des photomontages et paraît-il
terminée mikhaïl gorbatchev réclament la
vérité historique
les le droit des révolutionnaires vos
karine zinoviev kamenev a une chance
d'être réhabilité le nom peut être même
l'image de trotski pourrait réapparaître
dans les mains de l'histoire soviétique
enfin si l'on peut pas demander d'un
jour à l'autre des changements mais tout
de même là la direction qui a pris 6
watts chef de lettrés louable établir la
vérité d'ouvrir les fenêtres
l'information de la vérité de tours 2
jeu démocratique dans les fabriques
aussi incertain c'est un bon
commencement
contrairement aux rumeurs trotsky ne
sera pas réhabiliter même par mikhaïl
gorbatchev qui le considère toujours
comme un ennemi du léninisme
mais pour la première fois au sommet de
l'état soviétique le secrétaire général
en personne a prononcé son nom jacques
chirac en israël prière et recueillement
ce matin sur les lieux qui commémore le
low cost cet après midi devant la
knesset le premier ministre a plaidé
nouvelle fois pour une conférence
internationale sur le proche orient
il a également affirmé qu'il ne se
rendrait pas à damas en syrie
tant que ce pays ne fera pas un geste
significatif envers les juifs syrien qui
désirent immigrer en israël
jean-louis le sel nous n'ouvrirons ceux
qui ont si lourd tribut pour préserver
la liberté de la france
on se regarde et les valeurs
universelles de naître la civilisation
commune
c'est l'image forte de la journée
jacques chirac à l'institut yad vashem
qui perpétuent à jérusalem le souvenir
des martyrs et héros de low cost le
premier ministre se dira bouleversé
deuxième temps fort cet après midi la
visite à la knesset discours chaleureux
du président même si l'absentéisme
parlement israélien est aussi important
qu'ailleurs
entre temps monsieur chirac n'aura pas
ménagé sa peine il aura vu toutes les
personnalités qui compte de l'état
israélien
à commencer par le premier ministre en
exercice monsieur shamir a tout il leur
a expliqué que les temps ont bien changé
depuis les petites phrases acerbes du
général en 1967 et qu'on peut être
aujourd'hui héritier du gaullisme et
aimer israël
évidemment il subsiste des divergences
et des divergences de taille entre les
deux pays
mais ce voyage est avant tout un voyage
d'atmosphère accueillir par exemple les
familles de refuser ni retenue en urss
vaut les honneurs des gazettes au chef
du gouvernement français bien sûr
jacques chirac est également reçu ici en
tant que candidat virtuel à l'élection
présidentielle de 88 une raison de plus
pour ses interlocuteurs de le choyer et
pour lui de manifester aux israéliens
des sentiments d'estimé
amitié même si le premier ministre
répète qu'à son avis le vote juif
n'existe pas en france tout au plus se
reconnaître dans son entourage qu'un bon
voyage en israël ne rapporte pas une
seule voix mais qu'un mauvais peut-on
faire perdre beaucoup
alors toutes les conditions étaient
réunies pour que celui ci soit réussie
au canada la mort de rené lévesque
l'ancien premier ministre du québec
avait 68 ans certains firme qu'il
personnalisé à merveille l'intuition au
pouvoir un pouvoir qu'il avait occupée
je vous le rappelle pendant près de neuf
ans récemment lors du sommet de la
francophonie paul nahon avait rencontré
rené lévesque
l'homme était revenu à ses premières
amours le journalisme l'espace d'un
sommet rené lévesque était revenu à ses
premières amours le journalisme
journalistes pour la télévision
canadienne
c'était lui qui avait couvert la réunion
des pays francophones à québec en
septembre dernier la tenue à québec de
ce sommet lui tenait particulièrement à
coeur
lui le chantre de la francophonie lui
qui avait réussi en tant que premier
ministre en 1977 à imposer le français
comme seule langue officielle au québec
la france le français était raison de
vivre je l'avais rencontré au cours de
ce sommet un sommet comme celui ci ça
sert à quelque chose vraiment
recruté à tous points de vue vous
pourriez posé la question à quoi sert
l'onu qu'on passe son temps à dire monde
le nul en sortant le grand chose mais si
l'onu n'était pas là si le sommet
francophone au nicaragua il faudrait
l'inventer
ben moi je crois qu'après 20 ans de
tergiversations c'est le temps je savais
où un exemple simplement sans compter
tout le reste un exemple vous avez des
poussières de pays qui s'appelle la
dominique wiel maurice les seychelles
qui sont à la fois dans les clubs ont
encore très fragile début tendu de la
francophonie est également encore loin
des raisons historiques et c'est un à un
ses petits l' écoute pour qu'ils y
existe pas c'est au moins une chance
pour les tout-petits et les pauvres de
se faire entendre à l'occasion une somme
sans compter tout le reste
un sommet quels qu'ils soient même si je
suis plutôt à nous il ya juste un milieu
un jour de pluie pour ce qui regarde ça
de l'extérieur autour c'est important
messieurs françois mitterrand le chef de
l'état vient d'adresser un message de
condoléances à la veille de la veuve de
rené leveret qu'il écrit notamment le
québec a perdu l'un de ses plus
illustres hommes d'état voyons
rapidement les autres télégramme de
l'étranger avec rémy roche
le dollar confirme sa tendance à la
baisse sur les marchés monétaires
internationaux et notamment par rapport
au mark allemand et au yen japonais
stabilité du franc français qui reste
pourtant fragile pour cause de toussaint
la bourse de paris était fermé
aujourd'hui à new york après une
ouverture à la baisse l'indicé dow jones
est à la hausse
dominique cervelle le médecin français
qui avait disparu au salvador depuis 12
jours et sané secours vient sécurité le
secours populaire français dont elle est
membre fassis qu'elle a dû se cacher
pour échapper à l'armée salvadorienne
la nouvelle de sa localisation est
confirmée par le quai d'orsay
moderne et décontracté à ausy yang 69
ans le nouveau secrétaire général du
parti communiste chinois plus jeunes les
membres de l'équipe dirigeante également
élu après huit jours d'un congrès qui a
marqué un net avantage des réformateurs
sur les conservateurs en fausse retraite
versée au ping garde le contrôle de
l'importante commission militaire du
parti quant aux etats unis une première
chirurgicale qui ne passent pas
inaperçus les chirurgiens de l'hôpital
de pittsburgh ont réalisé une quintuple
transplantation d'organes sur un enfant
de trois ans l'opération a duré près de
quinze heures et aux dernières nouvelles
la petite fille se portent bien alain
labouze cette petite fille de 3 ans
était condamné une malformation
congénitale de l'intestin l'empêché en
effet d'absorber toute fioriture solide
son système digestif se trouvait dès
lors fragilisé est la seule solution
pour la sauver était de tout remplacer
un morceau d'estomac l'intestin grêle
une partie du côlon le foie et le
pancréas l'avis de tabata foster n'était
suspendu qu'à un fil mais sa mère
continuer d'y croire
elle a été par deux fois aux portes de
la mort c'est un bébé miraculé du dieu
est âgé qu'elle les chirurgiens de
l'hôpital de pittsburgh décide alors de
tenter le tout pour le tout l'opération
de la dernière chance qui consiste à
transplanter sur la petite tabata les
cinq organes prélevés sur un bébé décédé
à l'âge de deux mois
l'opération va durer siens heures 15
heures au bout desquels le chirurgien
thomas starr sel se déclarera optimiste
il est encore trop tôt pour affirmer que
tabata s'en sortira définitivement mais
une nouvelle fois les chirurgiens nous
ont montré qu'en matière de
transplantation d'organes tout était
possible
le sport jean ma mère on commence par un
coup de chapeau une petite française qui
marche bien c'est à tillières dans les
rues de new york
le reconnaissez jocelyne villeton 3e au
championnat du monde du monde de rome
et l'on découvre grâce à new york
françoise bonnet deuxième est fière du
marathon de new york
grâce à un finish éblouissant sur
central park et pourtant et pourtant
elle avait débuté très mal comme elle
l'a expliqué à notre cause pendant notre
envoyé spécial paul nahon à new york en
début de course je n'étais pas très bien
dans les dix premiers kilomètres d'abord
j'appréhendais un j'avais peur de partir
trop vite peut-être pas pouvoir tenir
sur les temps je m'étais fixé et puis
j'étais plus en ce sens et pas tellement
bien la course et puis ensuite quand je
suis arrivé à mi-parcours au 20e
kilomètre je suis sorti très euphoriques
j'ai doublé des vestes doublées des
filles et c'est là que j'ai senti que
j'allais réaliser quelque chose de bien
et vous êtes senti porté par les
spectateurs qui étaient autour
oui surtout dans central park c'était
formidable j'avais l'impression d'être
sourd tellement les gens crier en plus
les gens encourager tout le monde et il
voyait une femme puisque j'ai terminé la
course en boulet de canon
voyez doublé des hommes et il était
vraiment ça très impressionné et facile
de courir avec un homme parce qu ils
vous entraînent il fait lapin peut
peut-être pas qu'il fait le lapin mais
on se sent plus plus encouragés en fait
en ce sens moins seul un est donc
pendant la toute là les trois quarts de
la course s'est accrue avec les hommes
ont doublé des hommes les hommes nous
encourager ils disaient tous chaque fois
au bout de l'ogre bonne chance c'était
vraiment formidable
elle a même doublé roger zabel par emile
a fini un sacré est un extérieur deux
heures plus tard on attend la
confirmation au championnat d'europe
ben c'est pas trop ça sera en avril a eu
en belgique et après la victoire de
sylvie borné à minneapolis en octobre
dernier l'équipe de france sera sans
doute très très forte ça peut faire mal
le tennis surprise cet après midi à
bercy notre champion à nous fait
merveille
c'était pas prévu ça ça on n'y pensait
pas thierry pour les intimes thierry est
champion a causé une agréable surprise
un délit mineur andres gomez tête de
série numéro 4 du tournoi de bercy et
jouer en numéro 9 mondial en deux sets
du vrai travail de champion thierry a
été il faut le dire notamment au service
particulièrement précis et puissant et
quand nécessaire à nice pour conclure
son jeu
c'est bien fait thierry champion a
affiché une grande sérénité tout au long
de cette partie face il faut dire un
andres gomez totalement hors du coup et
qui à chercher son tennis que l'après
midi besogneux au service et dans les
retours il a commis un grand nombre de
fautes directes il a subit constamment
le jeu très délié de thierry champion
très rapide en déplacement et auteur il
faut le dire aussi de jolis coups
d'audace même sur cette balle de match
victoire en deux sets 6 3 6 4
et bien pour un champion france surtout
lorsqu'on sait qu'il n'est que 168e
duong
en deux mots la suite ce soir sur
antenne 2 avec un match 100% française
22h15 m3/heure la case sur antenne 2 le
comte contre jean philippe floriot la
météo la météo on est toujours dans le
brouillard alors si j'ai bien compris
effectivement riz nous sommes toujours
dans le brouillard les brouillards sont
flemmards les brouillards sont reynard
les brumes nous enrhume et les anciens
avait raison quand il disait que
novembre est malsain et qu' il fait tout
cédé toussaint c'est un dicton qui en
dit long
en tout cas pour demain il fera plus
frais nous allons le voir dans une
seconde maintenant dans la couleur du
ciel la voici pour la journée de demain
vous verrez que sur la bretagne la
normandie le val de loire le centre le
nord est l'est la bourgogne enfin bref
toutes les régions veiller que je trace
au delà de mon de mon petit crayon donc
les régions au nord de cette ligne que
je viens de vous tracer nous aurons des
brouillard tenace débrouillards ce
qu'ils vont pratiquement resté toute la
journée avec des nuages bas et puis au
sud de cette ligne
le soleil réapparaîtra avec tout de même
une petite nuance pour le pourtour
méditerranéen où là nous assisterons à
des entrées d'air maritime les
températures je vous disais sont à la
baisse par rapport à celle d'aujourd'hui
voilà bien longtemps que mes pions pas
descendu au delà au dessous de 9 de 10
degrés voici un petit 9 degrés ici à du
côté de de nancy elles ont dix degrés
dans l'est avec une pointe à 22 degrés
dans les régions de corse et il fera ici
dans cette région là il fera 15 degrés
ou aono en eure et loir
célèbre pour ses d'un et dindonneau bien
sûr alors que demain nous célébrerons la
saint-hubert et que le soleil à 7h41
pour se coucher à 17h27
prochain rendez vous d'information 20h30
exactement l'heure de vérité avec pierre
méhaignerie
23h30 dernier journal avec aubry et de
l'air demain à 6h45 ouvrez l'oeil comme
tous les matins avec télématin habitants
- carl invité des 4 vérités sera jacques
chirac le premier ministre répondra aux
caisses
de gérard morin en direct de jérusalem
en attendant excellente soirée sur
antenne 2 je vous retrouve demain 20
heures
bonsoir